william julier bonjour
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
ce matin alors un dossier compliqué un
dossier très dense en tout cas pour
commencer rappelez-nous quels sont les
enjeux aujourd'hui à la fois pour le
groupe lafarge mais aussi pour les
plaignants
principalement il ya deux ans j'aurais
décision qui devrait être rendu
aujourd'hui on va voir si c'est le cas
il ya eu un premier report il ya
quelques semaines le premier enjeu
concerne les parties civiles vous l'avez
rappelé dans votre dans votre sujet il
ya quelques minutes les parties civiles
sont au nombre de trois l'association
sherpa qui est une partie civile une
association pardon qui
s'occupe de défendre les victimes de
crimes économiques
il y a ensuite le centre européen de
défense des droits de l'homme qui est
une association qui défend plus
généralement les problématiques liées
aux trois humains et constitutionnels et
puis une troisième partie civile
qui s'appelle live comparer ce qui est
une association qui a été créée à la
suite des attentats du 13 novembre et
qui donc que défend les victimes et bien
de ces attentats il y aura peut-être
nécessiter de vous apporter une petite
précision sur la raison pour laquelle
cette partie civile c'est la souhaitait
se constituer dans le dossier lafarge
donc pour ces trois parties civiles
l'enjeu est de savoir si elles vont être
autorisés ou pas à participer à
l'instruction à rester dans le dossier à
l'instruction avoir comme vous l'avez
dit accès au dossier et a demandé un
certain nombre de choses cette
recevabilité avaient été
considérées comme valables par le juge
d'instruction dans un premier temps et
puis ensuite la chambre de l'instruction
avait considéré que les parties civiles
ne pouvait pas continuer à être dans le
dossier afin pourvoi en cassation a été
interjeté et puis la cour de cassation
va se prononcer sur ce point là le
deuxième enjeu principal de la décision
qui va être rendu aujourd'hui concerne
la mise en examen pour complicité de
crimes contre l'humanité donc le chef de
mise en examen le plus grave lafarge est
resté mis en examen après l'arrêt de la
cour d'appel du chef de financement de
terrorisme et la cour de cassation va se
prononcer maintenant sur la question de
savoir
lafarge va ou non être mis en examen
pour cette infraction la pub mais au vu
du dossier justement cette accusation de
complicité de crimes contre l'humanité
c'est une décision possible de la cour
de cassation aujourd'hui on peut s'y
attendre
c'est jamais évident de savoir à quoi on
peut s'attendre avec une décision
judiciaire
l'enjeu juridiquement est de savoir si
le fait pour lafarge d'avoir su que
certains sont revenus pouvait finalement
être remis en fin de course à dael
constitue ou pas ce qu'on appelle en
droit l'élément intentionnel de la
complicité de crime contre l'humanité le
débat juridique est de savoir s'il faut
pour lafarge avoir adhéré au projet
terroriste lui même ce que soutiennent
certains et puis de l'autre côté
notamment du côté de lafarge on va venir
dire évidemment ne soutenait pas le
projet terroriste et le simple fait
d'avoir eu connaissance de ce que un
groupe qui pouvait peut-être in fine et
recevoir des fonds et bien se livrer à
un plan concerté d'élimination d'une
population et bien que cette
connaissance là qui n'est pas celle
d'une adhésion au projet ne suffit pas à
fonder la complicité de crimes contre
l'humanité voilà le débat que la cour de
cassation va devoir trancher et vous en
parlais tout à l'heure pourquoi
certaines ong ont souhaité se porter
partie civile justement dans ce dossier
à écouter déjà on peut se féliciter
qu'il y ait des ong des associations
qui souhaitent se porter partie civile
c'est un peu l'ironie de la situation si
ces associations
je n'ai à ne plus avoir le droit de
participer au processus parce que c'est
elle qui l'ont lancée au même titre que
dans un certain nombre d'autres affaires
on a un autre exemple qui va peut-être
donner lieu à l'ouverture d'une
information qui est très récent il ya
quelques semaines une ong qui s'appelle
200 free a saisi le parquet national
français anti terroriste d'une plainte
contre le géant sucrier castel qui est
un groupe français qui fait 5 milliards
de chiffre d'affaires annuel en rapport
avec des exactions considéré comme il
centrafrique donc chers pas le centre
européen de défense des droits de
l'homme et puis ensuite dans un
troisième temps leicester paris ce sont
ceux qui vont avoir mis en route cette
procédure que le parquet ensuite va
considérer suffisamment valables parce
que aujourd'hui des poursuites sont
conduites par le juge d'instruction en
accord avec le parquet sur un certain
nombre de qualifications et donc ce sont
ceux qui mettent en route la procédure
qui finalement aujourd'hui pour des
raisons peut-être plus technique et
juridique que d'opportunités risque de
se trouver mise à la porte du processus
qu'elle même et bien ont mis en place on
verra ce que la justice décide il y a le
droit et qu'il y à aussi
voilà derrière peut-être l'equilibre
qu'on souhaite trouver entre les
intérêts économiques et de l'autre côté
des associations des ong qui font primer
les droits humains sur les intérêts
alors en quelques mots pour conclure
justement qu'est ce qu'elle dit la loi
concernant ces ces entreprises
françaises qui sont basés à l'étranger
sur des territoires dits sensibles
de quelle juridiction dépendent cesser
ces entreprises finalement est-ce
qu'elles ont des contrôles comment
est-ce que ça se passe et on va
peut-être parce qu'on a peu de temps
reste est resté au droit français et
ensuite des mécanismes aujourd'hui
d'extra territorialité qui permettent
d'ailleurs
voilà des fois des états qui ne sont pas
directement concernés par l'activité
d'une entreprise française de sang-mêlé
on l'a vu avec toutes les dispositions
de la loi sapin qui sera d'ailleurs ma
conclusion
il y à un mouvement depuis quelques
années qui prend de l'ampleur en droit
français mais pas seulement dans
d'autres pays européens
qui est celui d'exiger une moralisation
de la vie économique plus seulement en
rapport avec des problématiques
internationales et transfrontalières de
corruption ça ça a été ce qu'on a appelé
la compliance le fait que les
entreprises en 16es rôle des
multinationales doivent dans l'exercice
et dans la conduite de leurs activités
économiques notamment avec des filiales
et bien mettre en place des processus de
prudence de manière à s'assurer et bien
qu' il n'y aura pas de corruption de la
même manière on est en train de se
diriger je m'en félicite
vers la naissance d'une autre type de
comply hans comme on l'appelle en
anglais qui est celle de la compagnie
des droits de l'homme c'est qu'on va
exiger de plus en plus tu des entités
françaises travaillant à l'international
et bien qu'elle met en place des
processus de prudence pour s'assurer et
bien qu'il n'y aura pas au bout de leurs
activités des violations de droits de
l'homme ça touche des domaines qui sont
assez variés on l'a vu de quoi vous avez
fait un sujet sur ce point il ya
quelques semaines concernant la mise en
examen de la société amesys il vendait
les matériels de surveillance en egypte
et en libye on l'a vu dans certain
nombre de dossiers et c'est un pan du
droit et du contrôle aussi judiciaire et
sociale qui prend de plus en plus
d'ampleur et comme je le disais on ne
peut que s'en féliciter
il va y avoir de plus en plus une
prudence des grands groupes quant à la
surveillance de ce qui se passe en
particulier dans des zones sensibles et
dans des zones qui peuvent être
considérés comme à risque au plan des
problématiques de terrorisme ou au plan
des problématiques de conflits notamment
guerre civile et autres autres types de
difficultés de cette nature merci
beaucoup il aime juliette nous avoir
éclairé ce matin je le rappelle vous
êtes avocat spécialiste en droit
international